viajar durante la pandemia es cada vez
más fácil en francia ahora los viajeros
pueden presentar un resultado negativo
de la prueba a través de una aplicación
de rastreo conocida como todos contra el
kobe y a partir de la semana que viene
también se podrá usar para mostrar las
vacunas aplicadas una nueva función
llamada cartera permite a los usuarios
reunir todos los documentos sanitarios
en una carpeta pronto se probarán los
vuelos a córcega si a los territorios
franceses de ultramar posible me parece
bien que haya una aplicación que
centralice toda esa información es más
claro y práctico estaría dispuesto a
usarla siempre y cuando sepa quién
tendría acceso a mis datos necesitaría
saber que se toman medidas concretas
para que mis datos sean confidenciales
se espera que la nueva función trabaje
así los centros de salud autorizados
para hacer pruebas y vacunar envían los
resultados a la seguridad social
francesa una vez verificados la
seguridad social francesa envía los
documentos a los usuarios a través de un
mensaje de texto entonces los usuarios
pueden subirlos a la app que genera un
código específico para el usuario y que
tendrá que escanear antes de viajar en
francia algo
debaten si el pasaporte podría
utilizarse para algo más que viajar para
entrar en festivales e incluso en
restaurantes pero por ahora el gobierno
dice que sólo se utilizará en
determinados casos bosque intenso y tabú
no creo que sea una buena idea utilizar
este tipo de aplicación para entrar en
un restaurante o una tienda pero podría
considerarse para eventos con gran
afluencia de público la cuestión pues a
medida que se acercan las vacaciones de
verano a francia espera que la app
facilite los viajes y permita levantar
las restricciones en casa